you
grandpa can I meet him he isn't here yet
darling and this is a business meeting
we'll arrange it for another time come
in come in my boy I was just fending off
some of your rabid fans now sit down
I called you here to thank you sir for
the success of your interview you
surpassed my wildest expectations I'm
just saying how I felt which makes it
all the more effective you know the
difference between reality and
destructive adolescent fantasies you
were always the thoughtful one less
impulsive than Katniss
if Panem follows her arrow into a civil
war we'll witness something far worse
than the dark days she never wanted a
war and there won't be one if Peeta
Mellark still has anything to say about
it I don't know what more there is for
me the same
I'm sick of the blood
and for what I've seen it's more in the
hands of the peacekeepers there might be
a hundred things in a home that need to
be fixed but that doesn't justify
burning it to the ground we agree a war
might end humanity keep saying that with
the sincerity that comes so naturally to
you mr. Mellark sometimes in this world
whether we intend it or not we become
symbols prim since I am a symbol of
power and formality like the seal on the
door which means I can't always reach
into a living room that has to come from
a friend from someone people feel they
might know a baker's son the sooner
these uprisings are put to rest the
sooner you'll see your home again so
you're asking me to be what sir you're
voice of reason we've understood
everything but one small detail I'm not
asking